oh yeah
just got back baby just got back off the
road
and um
just i'm gonna go out to eat in a little
while
and so i'm trying i was trying to get me
a little tight a little uh tied over you
know snack
a little
i had me about nine almonds
and um
and it had me two yogurts
i'm gonna be honest with you
um
you know there's a time in my life where
i uh
uh you know
i probably wouldn't have told anybody
that i had yoga right especially a man i
wouldn't say hey man i just had him
just had some yogurts
you know what a lot i i had a lot and
not a
i'd have said yeah i just had some more
you know
some ice cream or something or some you
know real warm ice cream
um
but i like yogurt man i like it but then
there's that
i mean the thing it feels like you
shouldn't be eating it
and i'm not sure if i've spoken about
this before but it just feels like you
just shouldn't be having it doesn't it
it feels like you shouldn't be having it
um
it just feels a little uh
is it maybe it's just in my head it
tastes like a i mean look i'm a per you
know i got a little bit of you know i
got about probably seven percent pervert
in me so when they crack me open
everybody's gonna be a little pervert
jumps out and run you know
runs across the morgan you know
up under the lockers or whatever
but um
but yeah so i you know i don't i
but there's something about it's just
there's something about having a yogurt
that just feels it's like
i feel like there's the part of me
that's that's it
that's really uh i don't know it just
seems like it's almost a little it
seemed a little young or something i
don't know if that makes any sense to
anybody and i may be insane
but um
what's going on guys um
just got back off the road
i'm gonna talk about that um
[Music]
went to dinner the other night
went to like a fancy place you know just
kind of faint just
just i mean just damn look like we're on
the titanic you know i was just waiting
for the whole restaurant to just fill up
with water
that's how nice i mean people just
good day you know
you know people just being you know
friendly nobody yelling the n-word
nobody doing nothing just a good place
you know
and um
and
and we went and we were sitting by i was
sitting i guess by this couple and i
think it was like a first date or
something or maybe second date and this
lady had these bangers baby
she had these damn front honeys on her
baby i mean like a couple of damn
freaking milk bears
and they were just getting ready for
spring you could see them just kind of
um she had kind of a revealing kind of
top on
and you could see these big white damn
just a couple moby dicks you know what
i'm saying
and she had on like a lot of powder kind
of different powder you know maybe body
powder or something
and she probably put about probably a
half ounce up between them um
you know between them between them uh
them premier bunnies baby
between them that you know
them hammer time front yams baby she'd
really she put a lot of powder so
anyway some guy this guy she's on a date
with is making her laugh he's telling
her jokes
and they were the worst jokes right
they were like just uh what was one
it was like what's um
oh what's the tallest building in the
world
and
it was like oh it's a
it's a library because it has so many
stories that's what he would say and she
would just die laughing right and i was
like kind of jealous she was having such
a good time
but when she would laugh then
her chest would kind of juggle and just
that powder would just i mean
just buffing up just
just muffling just mufflering up out of
them um
out of them big nodules baby you know
what i'm saying out of them big uh out
of them big yogurt wagons dude just that
powder was just
like a um
it was like it was like her tits were
vaping or something
you know it was like her it's like her
breasts were like hitting a thing of
blue ice or whatever
i mean it was j and it was and so then
it would kind of stop and then he would
tell another one
and it was i mean just like it was
like aaron brockovich was going to show
up or something you know it just had
that
it was you almost wanted to call the
city i mean it just got real smokey over
there um
but
yeah that was something that happened at
dinner we went with this one gal she had
curled her hair so tight i mean you ever
have somebody they curl her hair just so
tight
i mean just tight tight
she couldn't even get her eyes and i saw
every now and then just kind of getting
some water out of glass and rubbing it
on her eyes because she had just
tightened that hair she locked it
she's so locked open
you know i almost wanted to just undo a
couple of the curls so she could uh
you know get half a blink in baby she
was real tightened
up um
but
anyway i was grateful to be eating and
uh
i um
i wasn't even gonna do an episode but i
i really i decided
uh that i wanted to be here with you
guys
i wanted to be here with you i
um
i wanted to be here with you
you know i want to thank everybody who
who ventured out this week
uh it was
we we had a couple of different shows we
started and did a small one-nighter over
in lexington
and then we hopped over to um
where was it then we hopped over to
lafayette indiana
and we actually had a call that came in
right here from a lafayette uh visitor
to the show here we go
hey theo my name is devin and i've been
a fan for years listening podcasts for a
while
what's up devon
and thank you for making the call devin
is a famous english name devin
hello devin
oh it's devin he's come
he's come looking for his dad
let's hear more brother
me and my buddies just saw your show in
lafayette indiana last night we drove
four hours in the snow to get there and
man it was hilarious and uh you know
last year
really bad year for me i you know had a
girl rip my heart out my chest and i
suffered from a motorcycle accident and
i just want to thank you for the part
that you played and get me back on track
because i'm doing real well now and it
was just really nice to see you last
night
you know it was everything i thought
would be is [ __ ] hilarious dude so uh
you know gang gang thank you thank you
gang baby thanks for the call devin and
thanks for coming out there yeah it got
ah
i mean mother nature you know she
started serving that eight ball it got
real
it got icy out there
and it was right the bus was heading in
we parked in the back and it was just
the snow started building up it was
coming down it was
i mean [ __ ] it was damn romantic almost
you know made you wanna
made you want to touch your own penis
almost
glad you came out
i'm glad you guys came out and uh they i
think somebody i hope everybody made it
because they had a couple empty seats
and i thought this somebody
cause it was inclined uh it was
inclement weather
it was inclement weather man
it was uh
you know it's the kind of something you
send your spouse to the store you know
if you want you don't want them
you know hey judy why don't you go
get me some of that uh prune juice
and next thing you know dang judy you
know
she goes she you know
that embankment gang maybe you know what
i'm talking about ripbc baby
yeah it was just an inclement weather
man so it was it was quite a time man we
you know it was a great
week of shows overall um
somewhere when we got to chicago it got
real fired up man that's when that that
crowd was electric
uh i thought the crowds at
at lafayette and at rockford which was
the next night
um
they were just it was just a little bit
more of a sedate vibe
honestly it just felt a little more
sedate in there
but a lot of great folks
everybody i met was great a couple nice
gifts i got
somebody brought me this into the wild
book
um
this is john krakauer cracker
got that hitter right here baby
that little lit hitter
from nicole gave me this another man
gave me an elon musk book
somebody oh this was the roughest bruh
so somebody sent me a um
somebody sent me flowers and a chocolate
you know
and i got backstage and the shower was
cold that was oh that was another thing
in
uh
in
lafayette which is where purdue indiana
is
the boilermakers engineering town and
these batches
don't even have a damn water uh heater
and it was cold in that dude i had a
shower it was so
cold bro i could hear dude i could feel
my i could
it felt like that movie ice age was
playing in my ass bruh
on six screens dude it felt like oh man
it felt like a damn woolly mammoth was
running around in my door
you know what i'm saying bro it was just
it was
there was no hot water in the thing so i
got in that shower bro and that almost
killed me man
that almost shook me down baby
that almost didn't get out that shower
almost didn't get out that shower boy
but anyway somebody sent the chocolates
there's a note on top and said i can't
wait for you to meet my son your son i
can't wait for you to meet your son
and i'm first i'm looking at your son
and i thought so you know
i thought your son was like a asian name
you know i did
so like
who's your son
you know i didn't know if it was like a
japanese guy or whatever so i'm just
thinking who's your son
i can't wait for you to meet yourself
and then um
i'm like oh my god your son
then my head goes oh my god
because this has always been a fear of
mine
you know i've had my penis in nuts a
long time and
and i've always suspected that this
could be
a reality
somebody drops off that tall bambino you
know they put him in a basket he's 14
but he's just in a basket on your
doorstep
you know it's that teenage easter all of
a sudden for you right there
uh and here was the crazy part then i
look over my tour manager standing there
tim
uh bizzle he's standing over there and
he's dying he's dying bro cause he saw
the look on my face i was like holy [ __ ]
somebody brought their
somebody brought my son
and um
and this was the wild part then i went
through like oh my god thank god
then i had a moment where i was like oh
damn bro
i wanted to meet my son dude
part of me was boom that i didn't get to
meet this son you know this alleged you
know possible son so that was uh that
was pretty that was that was quite a
moment and then somebody brought this
little baby dragon head or something
and they approached the stage with it in
chicago and that was a little
that was a little strange just looks
like a damn senior citizen like the last
look like before they take that last
bite of like a uh
maybe a little cake or something
if you got a grandfather
or something like that
let's look like maybe a
like a skunk got poisoned or something
but anyway some nice gifts thank you
guys who brought things um
what's going on man uh oh the news i see
this
they had a lawsuit against dennis
perkins in the livingston parish school
system alleges cynthia perkins
uh
they supplied semen
into cupcakes
and damn that makes you
i mean that you just
oh
that's like damn weiner fentanyl if
that's in a if that's in a baked good
that's you know
you just don't want that in there baby
you know and it's just
i guess that's where we're at is this i
mean it's
maybe people are starving i don't know
what's going on
you know i read grapes of wrath and uh
and at the certain point things get so
bad they're breastfeeding each other
but i can't imagine even in livingston
paris louisiana
um
they put it in pastries it says here and
energy drinks damn well look
the energy you could argue the energy
drink part but you can't i mean damn
you can't put a little you know
you can't put more
you can't put more
you can't
you can't be doing that
you can't be you can't be doing that on
the eclair bro you can't put more doodle
in a snicker bruh you know what i'm
saying dude um what else i'm not gonna
make this a real long episode today um
i'm gonna keep it pretty chill i'm
feeling a little under the weather i got
kind of sick actually in lafayette i got
that day i started having me a fever and
so i wasn't feeling real well and um
and here's another call actually that
came in from there let's go
what's up theo uh this is tyler from
dayton ohio
what's up tyler from dayton
and i spent time over there on in dayton
one time i was on a balcony man and i
was wishing this girl would uh
i was wishing this girl would make out
with me and she didn't want to
and that was it nothing and i just was
wishing and she
she wasn't wishing and that's
but they also got that at that flight
museum over there i remember
if you like flying or you want to get
into the sky somehow and you don't know
how
they can help you baby dayton
those [ __ ] want to be in the air bro
you see somebody on the ground in dayton
bro that's a little [ __ ]
let's go more dawg thank you for calling
i'm just driving home from your your
show in lafayette
uh
i just i just want to say thanks man it
is such a great time my first time
seeing you first time
at any comedy show uh
like i said i just want to say thanks
man for
being so vulnerable you know on the
podcast
and
helping everyone that you help you know
through their daily struggles i mean
you helped me just my day-to-day life i
mean
when i want to feel something
i just turn you on man it's uh
i'm so thankful that i started listening
to you
and i was finally able to come see you
uh
just want to say thanks man on behalf of
all your fans we love you
uh just wish you the best man
gang baby thank you
thank you brother um
yeah i love you guys too
you know i love you guys too
yeah it's been a long you know it's been
a
i don't know what it's been this is just
my life
and uh
and
yeah i'm just doing my best and i know
you guys are doing your best and so
yeah i'm just grateful that we kind of
have we have this space where we kind of
get to meet and when that's when i see
at shows i know i see that
there's a lot of people that are just
similar to me
um
they don't always know
what's going on
uh
and they just want everything to be okay
um and i i always get told that we have
the nicest crowds that show up i get
told every time
people say this is the nicest crowd
um
but yeah man i'm just doing my best man
and i appreciate you being uh
you know you're probably similar to me
that's one thing that people say
sometimes do you you know you like
meeting people at the show stuff i said
well most of these people are people
that i probably they they know so much
about me and we share so much callers
share so much
that
we've kind of
we probably would get along we'd talk
anyway if we just saw each other in
regular life so
uh
pretty cool man just happy to be a part
of this group and uh and thanks for the
call brother and thanks for coming out
baby
and thanks for coming out dude and lay
off them s cakes baby you know what i'm
saying dude dang
i can't believe them them teachers
serving them things
dude if you get a s plus on the if the
teacher gives you a s plus
that's a
that's an illegal grade baby that's
semen
damn a semen bro what are they doing
you gotta what you gotta go to hit you
know
ask a neighbor for something if you need
uh you know sometimes i know you don't
have a certain product but ask a
neighbor
you don't look inside of your body to uh
to complete a recipe for children
what else do we got man um i'm gonna
read you this real quick and then i'll
come back and uh
and i got a couple more things i want to
tell you about babel whether it's saving
more in spending less getting organized
or losing weight there's a lot of
worthwhile goals to set for yourself
this year
at the top of my list is learning a new
language with babel
b-a-b-b-e-l
it's a language learning app they sold
more than 10 million subscriptions
that's a lot
not only is learning a language fun it's
engaging but it's something you it
changes your life
you want to unlock a unlock guam unlock
damn sarajevo you can do it you got to
know the language maybe you show up over
there pointing this [ __ ]
somebody's going to pop off on you you
know i'm saying somebody's going to hit
you with that semen cake in the throat
baby you know what i'm saying they're
gonna serve you out them dirty recipes
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german that's right
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babble in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts games video stories and
live classes
right now
we got a deal for ya we got a deal for
ya
right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you get
an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of just
three go to babbel.com
use promo code t-h-e-o that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code theo babble
language for life
you know i'm gonna brush up on my
spanish and i'm gonna use babel that
will help me so i'm excited about that
um
what do you think riley mao would you
ever have a
semen cake would you handle have you
heard of anything like that what is that
in your culture what do they say about
that um i don't know i haven't heard
anything of that
all right
and have you ever and uh and yeah
i mean
i know you have a storied history with
seeming yourself and not even
you know never getting it out of your
own body
you know which is um
we've discussed it before right and do
you
have you ever seen semen is that okay to
ask you i have not
dang boy
dang
that's i mean there's just i feel like
there's a lot of it out there
but i'm proud of you man
thanks i'm proud of you man um
what's happening how are you uh i've
been well yeah you've been dating what's
going on give me the update i wanted to
know the uh
the ins and outs the ins and outs of it
yeah i mean um
there was this girl that i met over
facebook um okay and we
just started hanging out
and what does that mean you're hanging
out you guys are walking around you guys
are looking at stuff where was the first
date you took her
i took her to a music show oh okay
and did she like music were you guessing
that she liked music or had she done
something had she
had you seen her maybe do a get you know
you know
do like this with her fingers or do like
this or something had she given any clue
to that
no the only thing i saw that she loved
country music okay
and you could tell that how do you know
it i saw it on facebook oh
nice little recon huh
and when you saw her for the first time
uh did you meet her at the place
no i met her at a coffee shop okay you
met her at the coffee shop oh you met
her for the first time ever at a coffee
shop after seeing her online right and
did you meet her outside or inside
inside nice nice nice nice more chill
move yeah good and so what happened did
it had it had it escalated or how how
did it go
yeah i mean we at least what i thought
we were going on a couple of dates oh
okay
okay and what was it about it that you
that you liked or like if you had a name
if you had to name two things about her
that you like just one word
she's just uh just one more just one
word
she's cute
that's good
that's good and tall show me how tall
with your hand if you can
i mean she's probably
five seven oh that's nice boy
that's nice you need that at least i've
almost you got to have a decent amount
of woman you know
you want enough
you want enough because sometimes unless
the smaller ones they got more fire in
them
because the longer they get sometimes
they've run out of fire you meet a girl
six five and she barely
you know can't could barely keep her
eyes open because the gas can't get to
get up that high
um
and what happened did you uh
did you guys did it escalate into a
you know where did you guys ever make
out or any
uh no almost okay and what have you
so yeah so we were at a karaoke bar okay
nice and did you sing anything i did
okay good
good
look at you man did you pick out the
song no she did okay
wow that's good
that's good
and then what happened
um we sat next to each other um her head
was on my shoulder at one point
which shoulder my right shoulder oh yeah
and are you right-handed or left-handed
right-handed
um
okay would you rather she was on your
left shoulder you're okay with that i
was okay with it oh yeah
oh yeah
and then what happened did you have
because that's kind of when you move the
mouth down there and you kind of take a
chance right i should have oh were you
feeling it in your body at all did you
what were you feeling in your body i was
just feeling excitement okay nervousness
okay and when you're feeling erect or
anything like that or you're feeling
calm feeling calm okay
wow that's great
oh man and then what happened
then we left and i took her home
and did you did you try to advance it at
some point did you say you know did you
let her know what was going on like with
you or how did you know it because it
sounds like it's over now yeah so i i
told her a couple weeks later um
sat her down was like hey can we talk
and i just told her were you nervous i
was what were you feeling like i was man
i was so nervous she said give me four
words
happy
nervous
oh yeah
i can only come up with two oh yeah
that's hard and then that means a lot
was probably going on because yeah if
you can only come up with two words dude
and you had all those things going
inside of you
were you scared yeah okay scared
oh terrified damn so you were really
dealing with it all right so you sat her
down where inside um just in my car
oh yeah boy
and did you park or were you driving
park oh dude i like to keep driving if
things are going to be serious because
at least something's happening
but once you stop you're like
things feel real heavy right
um
or at least uh put on the wipers i do
something to create like some type of a
movement
but uh and what did you say to her
um i told her i i was like you know that
one song you know i really like you by
carly rae jepsen
she was like yeah so i said
cool well yeah that i i really like you
oh you just dropped it on her huh mm-hmm
and then what did you close your eyes
after that
no i kept them open oh that's brave as
[ __ ] i wanted to see your reaction oh
the gayest thing you can do dude and not
even like in a homoerotic way is just
say
something real and then just close your
eyes bruh oh that's unbelievable
that's freaking
serves whoever does that dude serving
one of them s cakes baby you know what
i'm talking about
um but um
no she basically said it was bad timing
bad timing why what uh
oh and you were still sitting in the car
yeah oh
oh
must have hurt did it yeah [ __ ] and were
you at her house you sell the driver
somewhere after no i was at her
apartment oh that's good so then it's
like she can leave and it's done right
but why would she say she it was too bad
timing
i mean just her family was visiting her
she had some friends from home and
visiting her um
stuff happened with her car stuff
happened with her car like what she had
car problems
how does car pro i mean
gosh
how does car problems
i never heard something you know
like you know
my blinker doesn't work or whatever so i
can't date you or whatever like that's
i don't that sounds crazy to me you know
yeah i like like i need like you know my
rotors are bad or whatever so i can't
fall in love or something like that
what did she what else did she say about
it
um i mean she just said that her car got
broken into
um which i mean that's crime that has
nothing to do with y'all's feelings i
don't feel like right
that's why i was really confused
and what else because you said car
problems
um she
she was at a church and her
wheel got stolen
jesus christ jesus take the wheel baby
damn that's just insane
look brother if you're getting stolen
from that church bro you bad luck that
lady sounded like witchcraft bro if they
if people stealing from you
you out there your shit's parked in the
lord's yard and somebody's out there
jacking your wheels baby
damn son that's
look that's that that's
you know that's
if that's what's happening man it sounds
like then maybe it was for the best dude
because that's crazy i'm having car
problems so i can't date like
but i guess
if your wheel gets stolen i guess it is
hard to date somebody huh
i guess apparently damn man
well i'm sorry dude i would buy i'd
honestly put a wheel on her car bro if
she'd go out with you right
so where are you back at now does ground
zero yep but still no masturbation huh
right unbelievable
dang big dog
you saving that thing boy my god
i know some political men that would
smell you nuts for probably a couple
thousand baby damn
well um good to see you feel healthy
i do yeah yeah you still growing i am oh
that's great man god you got a lot going
on then
you got a lot going on riley mal thank
you so much for being here and telling
us what's going on man thanks for having
me on
yep you bet dude um
what else is going on uh
let me see we had a couple more calls
that came in oh we got to chicago and
that was uh man
it was all awesome i mean it's all
touring is awesome you know it's like
you go when you get to see all these
people you see some of them in the
street you see some and it just like
like in lafayette i went down to the
ymca and got me a workout in right
before the show
so i'm running down the street some kid
work at a candy shop he comes running
out he's like
you won't you want some of these
caramels mother
and it was just you know just beautiful
you know it's just damn beautiful man so
just [ __ ] like that you know um
i'm trying to think what else happened
that was oh
oh in chicago we get there
and
there's a dude outside dressed as
captain america
and he was he stayed outside of the bus
for about two hours
and he stood out there and um
and he had a uh
his he had a sign
and i'll put this picture in the
youtubes so you can see
he had a sign on him and said something
uh i just saved the world but i can't
afford tickets to your show
which is crazy because there were 40
tickets available
so
that that's bizarre but uh but hey but
maybe that was a lot you know a ton for
him and so anyway we set him up with
some tickets and
um
yeah
and i mean he didn't even have mittens
on
and it was cold it was cold it was in an
alley in chicago
so that was pretty uh
i mean it's just crazy when captain
america is coming out to the show or
even just a third stringer
you know when they're coming out and
showing love man it was beautiful
um
what else happened
what else happened i
i gotta have my tour manager tim on soon
he he he is almost the memory
he acts as the memory um
we had yeah chance willie maddie smith
we're on the shows opening up tall alex
oh
and we got to chicago this was crazy we
got to chicago
and
it was just
i mean it's the biggest show i've ever
done
you know is
i think 35 something 35 something
hundred
and man it just
it was magical
even just walking in that place
and there was just so much love and
i wish i could have done a meet and
greet or or jumped outside there's just
it was cold and there's people rape i
mean people running to their cars
chicago's accountable you're walking on
the street somebody falls [ __ ] damn bro
you keep going i see people keep going
leave their fathers stuck in a crack
you it's just the weather is right there
jack frost is
i mean he's nipping at your nose dude
and he's wiggling at your ass bruh
you know i'm saying he's about to serve
an s cake bruh you know what i'm talking
about
he's about to serve one of them uh
tangent that one of those livingston
parish nut desserts baby you know what
i'm saying
that's semen cake baby that energy
damn what are they doing
i mean this kind of stuff has to stop
man
when i was young you jerked off and you
did it for you know
mostly for yourself only
um
bridge credit solutions i'll tell you
that
bridge credit solutions is different
i've used them
i couldn't get money to get my house i
couldn't get the right mortgage because
i had a couple of dings they call them
on my credit number
so i had to get them adjusted and
that was that
they helped me within i think six weeks
they had them tightened up and i was
then able to get a loan uh with a lower
interest so it saved me a lot of money
that's the facts
they're backed with 100 money back
guarantee for any items that cannot be
removed you will not find that anywhere
in the credit repair industry
you know exactly what you're paying for
at the beginning of the repair it's
written in the contract
bridge credit solutions caters to all
type of clients
they pride themselves on lightning quick
turnaround time and will guarantee
removal of certain negative items in as
quick as 24 hours
schedule your free credit audit in three
easy steps zoom or phone call
and get a free three bureau credit
report
with 30 days of free credit monitoring
and identity theft production when you
sign up at our link
bridge credit
solutions.com theo
once scheduled
uh bcs
uh
strategist will contact you to review
your report with you
bridgecreditsolutions.com
theo they work
they really work
um
what else
[Applause]
what else do we have
that happened i mean yeah it was just so
magical i wish i was feeling better i've
had a fever for about four days and so
my everything just feels kind of
i think that weather got me
um
but i'm trying to think of some other
stuff that
we were on the bus i mean the bus is
just you're just kind of
you know it's tight confines on there
and you breathe in a lot of the same air
so you can't get a lot of new ideas
because your air has the same it's
coming to your body and going out
so you basically just huffing the same
[ __ ] that's been in your brain
because
i mean you know
if you if you
have some an idea in your body in your
head and you breathe out it's part of
it's in the air you breathe it back in
then you just sitting there
you basically just
you just hot hoes hitting your own
freaking uh
poor choices sometimes at some point
but i wanted to
i wanted to come and be here with you
guys um i wanted to take a couple of
calls
and see what was going on in you guys's
world as well
um
what do we got right here
hey theo it is jessica from california
and i'm not sure if ladies are allowed
to call in
oh yeah ladies welcome
ladies welcome thank you i don't hear a
lot of that
uh anyhow i just want to say i'm really
taken by the last episode
the
uh episode you had solo
talking about ayahuasca and therapy and
all that
i went to peru myself into ayahuasca and
the way you articulated it was perfect
like giving your
like god giving the secrets away or
giving your heart a chance to talk was
really beautiful and spot-on
thank you very much yeah it's like
you're it's like your heart gets a brain
in it um
it's like your soul gets to fart kind of
uh
it's it
it's unbelievable i just got back from
another experience with it and i'm going
to talk about that a lot i'm not really
ready to yet i don't think or i just i
don't want to talk about it in our when
i feel like i'm on kind of a um
when i'm
i just want to feel a little more
settled this week has been just a ride
and last weekend is when i did the
ayahuasca uh the second time so this has
been just a and then i went right into
the touring so just been a wild week
let's hear more
and uh reminded me how much i need to
get back to it because i don't think
it's just a one-shot deal
and just thank you for your
vulnerability because you show a good
example
to men on how to be vulnerable i know
you probably don't think that way with
what you're struggling with but
it is good to have an example
to the masculine about how it looks and
what it looks like to be in touch with
yourself and
not to be scared of that so
you're doing great and
i thank you for your vulnerability and
you'll see around los angeles i live in
physio it doesn't matter okay um we'll
thank you again all right shooter shoot
baby
uh i love you young lady thank you for
the call
um
yeah you know i i don't really have any
other choice i don't think but to be
where i'm at in my life um
[Music]
and it is hard sometimes i feel you know
uh
sometimes i feel like a little [ __ ]
honestly in some ways i know that's just
a term right
but i didn't i need you know i think
part of me i grew a little i grew a
little [ __ ] in me because i didn't have
that motherly love i needed so part of
me probably sprouted a [ __ ] inside of
me
because i needed that it's amazing what
you will create what your
what you will create inside of yourself
when you need it
so
um
but anyway thanks for the words yeah i'm
just i don't know i'm just trying to be
alive and
uh
and yeah i just i don't know
uh the ayahuasca experience has been
it's been really amazing i don't know if
it's
i don't know i have a lot of thoughts on
it i'll i'll i'll i'll get into it at a
different time maybe next week um
when it just hasn't been such a jump
just uh
it just hasn't been such a time this has
been a long
little stretch i feel rattled right now
kind of all over the place um i'm trying
to make it down to uh mardi gras
to spend some time with my family in
louisiana
you know i miss uh
i miss
my hometown some and i miss my family
some um
and yeah i don't know i really just
i don't know i miss being around people
that i know really care about me and who
i care about
um
so i'm gonna go
i hope to spend some time doing a little
bit of that this week
so
what else what else do we have um
do you have any regrets about the lady
raleigh
i don't
uh did you uh do you feel like
she was into you do you feel like what
do you feel like
yeah um i felt like she was into me um
did you do something that sent her away
do you feel like there was a false move
you made no i didn't
damn man i feel for you
i feel for you
and do you feel like she had good
intentions with you oh definitely
okay
okay man
but you're out there you're looking for
love huh i am gosh you're right there on
the front lines aren't you
but you're not even yeah
damn and now what if you get her to a a
moment with a woman and she wants to be
sexual you know what i'm saying she
wants that livingston parish dessert
what you gonna do then
i don't know i don't think it'll ever
get to that point what
you know it has to huh
i mean at some point you have to
you know you just why you just think
you're not gonna have that uh any luck
with ladies
i don't know i don't know
so far not yet um
but how old are you now 23 oh you got
time to kill then man
i think if by 30 you haven't
maybe gotten a
you know at least
i mean what what are you allowed to do
sexually before you have to go to church
before you have to get married i mean
how can you have
any type of sexual interaction or just
actual sex you can't have
i think it's just actual sex you can't
have okay okay
so you can get a little feeling and a
little touchy touchy and do some heavy
hugging huh right okay
damn there you go
wow
bob man and you haven't even had a wet
dream or anything like that huh right
now
i'm surprised dude i'm surprised satan
didn't just pry open that little tuna
can bruh
damn brother
i'm surprised dude i bet a damn strong
wind comes up your spine the right way
dude you'll start
oh you'll water the pants
um
yeah thank you guys a lot of great calls
came in about uh the i about ayahuasca
stuff and thoughts like that and i will
get into it um
maybe next week i'm still kind of
sorting through some of my feelings
because you come out that thing and you
really a lot of your peel is gone so you
just you feeling just damn
you just heavy in the peach baby you
know
your peach is feeling real damp
so
um
would you ever try something like that
an exotic drug rally
um
i wouldn't really yeah god is your dope
huh
man i love it my god boy i want to cut
your damn arm up and eat that [ __ ]
um
what else you have any other you want to
say goodbye riley anything um actually i
now that i think of it i don't think she
had good intentions
who's oh the date right oh wow what uh
what made you believe that
i just feel like she was using me for
all my connections
what what do you mean your what type of
connections for
um for all of my bands her favorite
artists
oh
because you work in the audio and you
felt maybe she was using you right wow
any band in particular
uh
yeah shine down's one of them
look it's a
that's the world we live in riley and
that's the thing i don't know if i want
you out here with you uh you know
getting sprung out and hammering down on
these chickens bro because that's the
world we live in riley
a woman will come over here
and she'll freaking you know she'll rub
that little genie lamp or some little
christian
just to get some damn shine down tickets
out of them you know
and that's the kind of [ __ ] that breaks
my heart
oh
man
how do you know how are you going to
know in the future raleigh if they're
good if they you know
i guess it doesn't matter you just keep
trying huh right damn
that's it baby just throw your heart up
in the air and hit that [ __ ] with a bat
and then you just
you hope somebody catches it you know
you hope somebody catches it
and are you guys allowed to do
homosexuality in your church or not
i don't think so well
damn
riley mao guys
out here
getting taken advantage of
dark baby on the way out i want to tell
you um
that
the last website you will ever need
is now available from modify
m-o-d-i-p-h-y
they will build your site they built my
site theovonne.com
they will build your site they produce
awesome stuff
say bye-bye to overpriced logo designs
and old school contracts
you can have unlimited updates free
revamps
it's 4.98 to start and only 250 a month
after that no cancellation fees no
hidden fees ever
and
as a tpw listener go to
modifymodiphy.com
t-h-e-o to get 50 off your starting cost
that's right
cut that 498 and a half
and you'll have the last website you
ever need
modify.com
theo
um
yeah i'm excited to get to louisiana and
see my family i wanted to make this
episode because uh the same reason we do
you know we try to show up
so
um
you guys showed up for me this week
you guys show up for me every week
you know i don't think i tell you
sometimes enough how much you guys mean
to me and girls and just
uh
man i just feel
i don't know i feel like we're doing
something
you know i don't know what it is
[Music]
but i feel like it's the right thing
baby gang gang you know
so
you guys be good to yourselves uh you
deserve it and i'm gonna try and do the
same um let's hit this one on the way
out
this is robert finley get it
while you can
[Music]
off his album going platinum
[Music]
robert finley
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you ever go to any of those church camps
raleigh mao
i have not wow you never have no
you never went to a church camp or
nothing
nada you ever been you ever been at uh
because i just don't see how you haven't
seen somebody else masturbating
themselves you know i feel like a lot of
times that happens with young men you're
somewhere else you see somebody
masturbate themselves
never witnessed anything like that huh i
have not you ever had a brother you have
a brother i do and have you ever see
walked in on him on accident or
something or you know bumped into him
real hard and he came or something
uh no i don't think so wow
wow y'all just have a different family
man uh
i feel like that's a lot of times a lot
of young men they learn it like that you
know they learn it like that you get
i'm sure there's probably if there's
anybody out there if you ever had a
brother you actually seen your brother
masturbate or something
you know and i'm not trying to be
you know nasty or whatever but i'm just
curious the effect it has on you can you
still
look at him the same as everything's
still okay between you uh
and if you saw him do you tell him
you let him know that or is that a
private thing and
you know or if or if your brother saw
you how did you handle that
you know how do you handle that
hit the hotline with somebody that might
be interested in chatter and we can
learn from each other 985-664-9503
um
what do you think on that rally
you heard the man
wrap it up
[Music]
yeah i want to thank bizzle gibbons i
want to thank uh
isaac heckert
um
for the support this week colin ryan or
riley mao jimmy rector everybody who
helps make uh
this podcast and uh
and the tour work
you guys be good to yourselves baby gang
love you
you